right there
[Music]
okay
foreign
I want here
here okay yeah I'm not doing one
here like this
right then as he goes to push I could
take this
over here he keeps pushing I go inside
wrap down push it out of the way
then you can add your movement
so I'm gonna move out
okay get out from underneath your
spiraling geometry okay so when I when I
go I don't want to Pummel in here on
this straight line
so I'm already rotating this fight and
he's gonna press again and not really
taking the fight again you see
it I know it looks doable you're all on
this straight line and you go here
but you want this thing to rotate boom
goes around boom
so I'm gonna turn it one way
he comes the other way oh he comes in
again and I'm inside
never hear any place I know it looks
doable but your performance envelope you
pushing you
foreign
[Music]
a lot of times when he's driving really
hard you can't turn into that thing
but this is where all sense is getting
healed comes in okay so I'm here to
surprise
just circle that last little bit
cool
okay let's try uh he does he might be on
your hip but he doesn't have to be on
your head okay so I'm moving this way
and the team now charges so fast there's
no way I'm going to do it inside turned
on that
so one I come out here
the key is that you're not hearing
shoving them you need him to go more
deeper and that's where oh sensei's
yield happens so he's pushing and
just like tenshinagan I'm here hit but
now I heal boom
[Music]
okay let's go
okay
[Music]
let more Yin the yin is way more
important than the Young
[Music]
foreign
here
so don't lose the head
you're still gonna pull this arm you're
still going to pull the arms okay ready
to sweep your weight
and he's still got some pressure there's
some pressure here okay pressure I'm
gonna go under
okay listen now let me help you with the
geometry okay look he's gonna do a
forward roll these things you're going
to do the front inward position
say yes yes so your body has to be
inside of that
okay so he's gonna do the front inward
position
well I can't be here
you see
and I can't be here
so I'm going to disappear
foreign
this switch goes in I turn and I'm going
to be here
okay I want to go all the way down
because I'm throwing the case at a time
and I'm not throwing just to throw them
so in and i s i sink inside of that
forward roll
see how you're fitting
foreign
don't leave your head up there
my body is connected to this hand oh
this hand drops it's going to drop with
me
okay
fix your geometry listen
[Music]
foreign
start again
doody like that again that was it
keep bring that head with you
there you go